Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa!
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you Ruffians for joining us today for our 6th episode!
As always, here we are for FUWAMOCO Morning.
As always.
It's our 6th episode, but as always.
As always, yes.
And FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO.
And it's hosted by us, FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts at us with the hashtag.
Hashtag FUWAMOCO Morning.
If you say it like that everyone's gonna smell it funny.
F-W-M-C.
You should know now, right?
Yeah, you know.
Right, Ruffians?
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Yeah, Ruffians, you know, right?
You know, right, yeah.
And this is just in!
There's been another Pero Sighting!
Ruffians, we saw Pero!
Where is he now?
Ruffians reported seeing him at... Where is this?
Medieval Europe?
A movie!
He's in the arms of a wizard.
The arms of a wizard?
He looks powerful.
Pero or a wizard?
I guess a wizard, but Moco-chan, do you think you could beat him up and get Pero back for us?
A wizard or Pero?
Both!
Maybe teach Pero some manners?
I think I could beat up Pero.
I think I could.
The wizard, I don't know.
He's wearing purple.
I really like the purple gown.
It's very suiting for him.
The way he's touching, he's just caressing.
Caressing Pero, yeah.
They're new friends.
But yeah, it does look like the wizard really, really taken a liking to him.
He's looking very wistfully at him.
You can see the love in his eyes.
Moco-chan, do you think we could ever get Pero back?
Do we want him back?
That's true.
He is pretty nasty, right, Ruffian?
Maybe we'll be okay without him.
But, you know, demon dogs also need to stick together.
So...
Pero is nasty.
Sometimes he can be not so nice.
Ruffians, please let us know if you have any more Pero Sightings, okay?
Remember to use the hashtag FWMCMORNING, okay?
Let us know.
We have to find him, I guess.
He'll be lost without us.
Well we have some good news too!
I guess if you tuned into a FUWAMOCO welcome or party you might already know, but Holo Abyss's original song, Rebellion, has hit 1 million views!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Thank you, Adventrix, for listening to it so, so much.
You've been listening, right?
You've been jumping up and putting your paws up and going, jump, jump, jump!
Maybe BAU BAUing a bit there, too.
Thank you!
Actually, my favorite part in Rebellion
It kind of makes me emotional too, but it's actually a part that Moco-chan and I, we both sing.
Well, we kind of split it in the middle, but it's the, I know that I can still be the future of my story.
You have to sort of sing it.
The future of my story.
It's a good part.
It means a lot to us, you know?
We hope that we can dance around with you and all of us together on a big stage, you know?
Would you like to see that, Ruffians?
Oh!
Shiori's plate's your favorite too!
It's my favorite too.
And Biboo's.
Thank you!
Oh, you know, actually, Mama Puppy says that she's been listening to it a lot.
It's kind of embarrassing.
Yeah, plus we don't really think she's the kind to listen to such a pop-pop party song, so it's a bit funny to imagine, really.
She really likes it, though.
Yeah, maybe it's a song that's popular with moms, too.
Ruffians, what do you think?
Would your mom like it?
Maybe you should let your mom know.
Yeah.
Yeah, my mom likes a song called Rebellion.
Rebellion.
Yeah.
Thank you!
It's a good idea.
Also, in more good news.
More good news.
Wow.
The demon of sound.
Not sound.
Yeah.
Yeah, the lovely Nerissa Ravencroft.
She's just released her brand new cover of Kami Poina of Godish!
Godish!
And you know what?
It is truly goddess.
Not soup, sound.
Sound, sound, sound, yeah.
Kamipoina, no.
No, there's no soup in there, but there's sound.
I think, for FUWAMOCO, when we think of Kamipoina, we immediately, we just can't help but think of Bae-senpai's amazing performance.
Yeah, it was too good.
Yeah, right?
At 4th Fest.
But, you know, Nerissa's Kamipoina, it stands out in a way that's totally unique to her.
It's Nerissa's goddess now.
Yeah.
And this time, you know, she's singing in Japanese, which with Love Me Love Me, it was in English, right?
So it's a bit of a different side, right?
You can kind of compare.
This is what Nerusa sounds like in Japanese.
It's a nice, like, different shift between the two songs.
Yeah.
Please, please go take a listen, go take a check out on it.
And let us know what you think in the comments too, okay?
Congratulations on the release!
Abyss strong!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
So much good news today.
What's the good news?
Well, and like always, we have our Misunderstanding Corner.
But, but actually... Actually!
What are you doing?
Today is something new!
We had no misunderstandings!
No misunderstandings.
It's our first time!
Yeah, are you proud of us, Ruffians?
Are you?
No.
Look, you know we went on it without any misunderstandings.
This is great.
It's good news.
Momentous day.
What do you mean, no?
No.
What do you mean?
Do you think we had some?
Do you think that we had some?
We'll find one!
You don't have to make them.
No misunderstandings today.
Very happy momentous moment.
You know, destroying all the buildings in EDF2, you know that wasn't a misunderstanding either.
That's why it's not on here.
That was just us having fun, you know, playing around.
Yeah, we did a good job of getting you apartments.
Yeah, we got you a new apartment.
We didn't blow it up, we got you a new one, okay?
Right?
Yeah, just cleaning the waste.
Yeah, it's not a misunderstanding, okay?
Yeah, Ruffians, you should be proud of us.
Yeah, proud of us.
Let's all hope for no more misunderstandings.
No, nothing about Sakura Wars.
No.
Yeah.
Let's all hope for more days without misunderstandings, okay?
What?
I'm happy about that one, Moco-chan.
It's a good surprise, right?
It's a really good surprise.
Also another surprise!
You know, we've been receiving more and more questions about Pero from the Ruffians.
You know, as we try to find out where he is, locate his whereabouts.
Information is important when trying to find him, right?
You know, Pero, he's been our pet for so long, we don't really think that
But now that he's not here, do you feel sort of lonely?
He's grumpy though, so like usually just the conversation kind of stops when we can stop it.
And yeah, you know, all of us, we did really appreciate his help, you know, helping us borrow things while we were on the cell.
It is important, I guess.
Yeah, you know.
No disrespect.
No, no, no.
But I thought, you know, at the very least, we thought maybe we could try and learn a little bit more about him since, you know,
He is an important part of our gang after all, right?
Look!
Ruffians!
We found something.
We found some of Pero's medical records.
Here we are.
It's his x-ray.
It's a bit personal, but you know, it's important.
It's important, you know?
Yeah.
What do you think?
Oh, you know, uh, I guess we kind of, uh, we didn't get his permission, but I think it's okay.
It's okay.
It's his x-ray.
Out of the room, out of the deal, like they said, right?
Yeah, yeah.
He's very fluffy looking, but maybe not so much on the inside.
No.
I think that's appropriate for him.
Look, he does have bones, though.
And, you know, if we need to take desperate measures, and he doesn't quite make it, you know, there's a bone for each of us to know, Moco-chan.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
We don't need to share this time.
Yeah, we can have one each.
Good.
Oh, that's very kind of you.
Yeah, very considerate.
Yeah.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
Flubbery.
Flubbery?
He sort of just goes around.
He's a bit fluffy, a bit fuzzy.
Yeah, but you know, I think there's bones inside.
I think maybe we shouldn't look much further, you know?
The mysteries stay mysteries.
Pero's Pero.
He has two bones.
Yeah, just two bones there.
Yeah, any further and it'd be a bit of an invasion of privacy.
No matter how you want to look at it.
Pero!
Thank you for your medical info.
Thank you for sharing it with all of us today.
Even though you didn't tell us because you're not here.
Thanks, Pero!
Thank you!
That was very kind, right?
Right, Ruffians?
Pero's spineless?
Yeah.
Ruffians, over the weekend we were on Kiara-senpai's holotalk with our holoalbum.
What did you think?
We played lots of fun games, right?
Games, we did pictures.
You know, we talked a lot about a lot of different things.
Thank you, Ruffians!
But yeah, you know, we were able to kind of learn a bit more about what makes Advent Advent.
And I had a lot of fun.
But actually, you know, Hiyara-senpai also mentioned how she was really surprised how serious we were and we were doing the warm-ups backstage in preparation and everything.
But you know, we also mentioned in the Crunchyroll, right?
Yeah, you know, we mentioned that we warm up every day.
Yeah, we always warm up our voices.
As Ruffians, as you know, we can get very emotional.
We're emotional puppies.
So when we're excited, we BAU BAU.
When we're scared, I guess we scream.
So you know, we're always making sure to take care of our puppies.
You know, because all that excitement and screaming could take a bit of a toll, you know?
And it's actually scientifically proven that your barker... Science.
We're talking a lot about science today.
But it's scientifically proven that your barker isn't awake until after 3 hours after you wake up.
So we always make sure to wake up 3 hours before a stream.
And then we always properly warm up for at least 10 minutes before.
But, as Moco-chan demonstrated, it can be a bit noisy.
It's a bit noisy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Right.
And sometimes, you know, we also do mouth warm-ups.
You know, like, can we do it together?
Okay.
Pretty little puppy, pretty little puppy, pretty little puppy, pretty little puppy dog.
Like that.
You know, it's important, you know.
You gotta get the mouth warmed up, the barker warmed up, those kind of things.
Very serious.
Yeah, you know, cause like, if we don't take care of it, then our barker will start to
Get tired and then it'll be hard to spend as much time as we want to with you.
We want to be able to spend as much time as we can together.
We're always making sure to take proper care of you.
Very important.
You know, we also drink a special tea and have cough drops.
It all helps our howls come out more smoothly.
It's always on our minds.
Ruffians, you make sure to take care of yourself too.
We actually...
We actually visited a very special doctor right before our debut.
It was a bit scary too.
We didn't really want to, but we knew it was important.
We went to see the doctor.
She did a scope to look at our vocal cords.
You know, BAU BAU'd a bunch.
We had to sing to all of Happy Birthday while she did the test too.
It was a bit scary.
Yeah, you know it's different singing with a camera down your throat.
Yeah, it's not... But it was really really worth it because she told us that our parkour looks really healthy.
Healthy.
Really happy and ready to howl.
Yeah.
Moco-chan, I was actually really proud of you too.
Moco-chan, Ruffians, did you know she's a very scary puppy at times?
I'm not!
I'm a big strong guard dog, okay?
Usually I try to get Moco-chan to go first, because if I go first, then she's going to get all scared.
And I accidentally went first.
But you know, Moco-chan did it without any complaints.
No tears, you know.
I had to be strong for the Ruffians.
But yeah, you know, we want to be able to spend as much time as we can with you, so being healthy is a very important part of that, alright?
You know, so make sure to have lots of water, lots of tea, do a warm up.
We'll make sure we continue to take care of the best of our Barkers, you know?
There's other things, you know.
Maybe not have so many Puppertinos, you know, because there's caffeine.
Caffeine is not good.
But most importantly, sleep.
Sleep.
We'll work hard at that part.
We need to work a bit harder at that part.
But yeah, Ruffians, please take care of yourselves too, okay?
Because, you know,
We're gonna take care of ourselves so that we can spend a lot of time with you.
So you need to make sure that you take care of yourself so you can spend a lot of time with us too.
Even if the doctor is a bit scary.
Even if the doctor is scary, yeah.
Okay!
Ruffians, you understand?
Okay.
BAU BAU!
Mococo did good!
I don't see that.
I want to see Mococo do good!
BAU BAU!
Okay, Ruffians, I understand.
Neru-san, you too!
That goes for you, Neru-san.
Wow, Moco-chan!
Let's take a look at our Doggie of the Day.
Today's Doggie of the Day is... It's Beck!
Beck is super cute!
Here it's written that Beck's charm point is her cute floppy face.
I have to agree.
Moco-chan, I'm fluffy, you're fuzzy, and Beck is floppy.
Makes sense.
So cute!
I want to ruffle and fluff the wrinkles.
I want to stretch.
Actually though, I was wondering, do you get maybe confused between what's the sofa and what's the back?
They look very similar, right?
A bit similar.
You know they have both the wrinkles?
Please don't get mixed up.
For Becca's sake, okay?
It could be easy, but...
How does Beck sound?
How does he BAU BAU?
I think Beck is maybe more like BAU BAU BAU.
She seems very reserved.
Very polite.
I would say Beck's reading is, you know, Beck's the best friend who loves to snuggle, watch shows together, maybe have a little popcorn that you drop here and there.
Fan of popcorn.
A soft sofa pal.
Very very cute.
Thank you!
Bye bye!
Bye bye Beck!
And for our next quitter, today I went for a walk.
You're gonna keep on messing up the title!
Today I went on a walk.
De-den!
You went to Comic Market!
Where you can see all the people of Tokyo Big Sight.
I feel like this is more like going into battle than just simply going for a walk though, right?
No, it's a bit different.
A walk usually isn't so...
What's the word?
Huh?
Intense.
Intense?
I was going to say fun, but walks are fun too.
Walks are fun too.
But we hope that you got some rare prizes and treasures.
Yeah.
You know, and hopefully you're able to stay cool despite the really intense Japanese summer.
But to be honest, I'm a little bit envious.
We want to go too!
And you know we saw on Twitter, we saw that there's some FUWAMOCO fanworks on sale too!
Why?
Too fast!
Ruffians!
How?
You're amazing.
Too fast.
You know, and there's even a Mococo cosplayer.
Right!
Oh Moco-chan!
It's happening!
Too amazing!
We're so so impressed.
Thank you Ruffians!
We hope you had a lot of fun and that you also got a lot of goodies to go home with too.
Thank you!
We're glad you had a good walk at Comiket.
A good battle.
And for our next segment, we have... Question of the Day!
What's the question today?
De-den!
Hashtag helpFWMC.
That's what you want to use if you have a question.
Do you girls go to the same class or separate class in school?
Tell us what the experience is like.
Have Fuwa-chan and Moco-chan got wrongly recognized by their friends?
Good question.
It's a good question.
Wow, you know we're in the South for a long time, so...
Oh, we had to kind of go back a bit, but... I guess when we were in guard dog training, sometimes we were in the same class, but sometimes we were separate, you know?
Sometimes it's just like that.
Yeah.
I think both were good and fun, good experiences, but being in the same class is more convenient because then, you know, we can keep track of any tasks or tests coming up and just study together, you know?
Yeah, you know?
Moco-chan, you're really good at taking notes.
My notes are cute.
I can look at your notes.
You don't need to take them.
But then sometimes we end up fighting over them too, and that's not good.
But you know, even when we're in separate classes, sometimes, even if the teacher didn't know that we were twins, they will remember us.
They don't need to remember us.
You know, sometimes you just sort of want to be...
Quiet.
Just ignore me, don't notice me teacher, please.
Thank you.
Just sneak in, learn, and go.
Maybe we're just a bit too smiley.
But as for getting wrongly recognized by friends, sometimes when people meet us for the first time,
Maybe at first you couldn't tell.
I'm Fuwawa, what makes me Fuwawa, and what makes Moco-chan Moco-chan.
But you know now, right?
You know now, right?
Of course, of course, right?
Yup!
Right, dot dot dot.
Yes, yes.
You can tell, dot dot dot.
There's some differences.
Right?
Like I have long hair, Moco-chan has short hair, you know?
You know the difference though, right?
Yup.
Thank you for the questions!
Very good questions.
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
Let's take a look at our next stream.
Our next stream is... De-den!
We have a super chat meeting, but you know...
It's not just Super Chat reading, you know?
This is actually, we're gonna be reading all the Super Chats that you sent us, especially for our monetization celebration.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
Yeah, you know we really wanted to be able to properly thank everyone.
Yeah, you know?
We really wanted to, but we're sorry that we made you wait a little bit.
Yeah, it's been a bit.
But finally, today we'll be able to say a proper thank you to you.
Again with that.
Today!
But we'll also be including a Super Chat Readings for FUWAMOCO Morning Episode 3.
Episode 3.
For Spooky Jump Scare Mansion No.n 2!
And then also for our Overwatch 2 collab with Bijou.
Yeah, and today's FUWAMOCO Morning 2.
As well.
We hope that you'll join us as we chat and we also say our thanks.
Our thanks for all your support too.
But going forward, FUWAMOCO Morning will be also included in the Super Chat Reading at the end of the day.
You know, the end of the stream.
So please join us for the evening stream too, okay?
We're gonna have a lot of chatting.
Thank you so much, Ruffians!
It's been a lot of fun today, okay?
Next, let's take a peek at our schedule.
This week, it's even more busy than the last.
Is that even possible?
I don't know.
But we have a lot of fun things planned.
This week too, just in time for the Oboe Holiday in Japan,
We're going to be staying up really late in the Northwest passes.
And we're going to be doing a Japanese chatting stream while taking some questions too!
I know we did a Q&A earlier, but this time we're going to be doing it in Japanese.
On the 16th, we'll be doing a Japanese chat stream!
It's our first time, so we'd be happy if you could join us.
I'm a little nervous.
The time will be a little different from FUWAMOCO.
We'll be starting at 5pm.
A little later than that.
We'll also be accepting questions, so please ask us a lot of questions.
If you use H-E-L-P or F-W-M-C, it will help a lot.
Also, if you listen to us as soon as possible, we might be able to answer your questions.
Please listen to us as soon as possible!
We want to get to know more and more Japanese Ruffians.
We'll also do our best to translate the questions that we get asked into English.
So maybe, you know, Ruffians that are still learning Japanese, we hope you can join.
And maybe it'll be less scary too.
Yeah, maybe it can help your learning.
Please join us!
But if it's really, really...
Thank you!
And then on Saturday, we'll be playing Zelda Ocarina of Time!
We're really really excited.
Good memories again.
It stands out to us a lot.
And I think, you know, we did beat it once with Mama Puppy at one point.
Yeah, I think maybe this is a link to the past, but those are probably the only games we beat.
But you know, we're gonna be playing it not on Switch.
We're gonna be playing it on N64.
I wonder if we still have the save data.
When we beat it.
Probably not.
It's probably been cleared since then.
That would be sad, but... We have to make new save data, you know it.
I know.
We've had so many special memories with MAMOPUFFY, but now we're gonna be able to have special memories together with the Ruffians playing it, so we're really looking forward to it.
Let's make lots of precious memories together, okay?
Well, the time has come, Moco-chan.
So fast.
Another end to a FUWAMOCO Morning.
But before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to say a special shout out to some of our Extra Special Viewers today.
Hattori!
BAU BAU!
Fry!
Joby Bear!
BAU BAU!
Woodam!
Chimes!
BAU BAU!
Rendon!
Take!
Take?
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
Howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!